having given the world k-pop south
koreans like to make a song and dance
about their elections
the two presidential front runners
especially
supporters of conservative hopeful yoon
sukyal wants you to remember his number
two when filling out the ballot paper
while the candidate of the ruling
liberal party li jam wants his number
one to get stuck in their heads
carefully composed and choreographed
there's a real art to creating the right
political ditty
by the time the candidate appears we've
already injected a certain energy we
prepare songs that have catchy lyrics
that people know well and dance moves
that everyone can do together
at this driving event for the democratic
party those moves are socially distanced
but intended to get the audience warmed
up routines like these are a vital
component of any campaign and the more
prominent the candidate the more
elaborate the performances become but
presidential hopefuls also rely
increasingly upon technology to connect
with voters
supported by some of the world's fastest
internet speeds online campaigning is
reaching new levels of ingenuity another
candidate who since dropped out on
charles held a news conference in the
so-called metaverse of the interactive
internet with real-life journalists
appearing as computer-generated figures
the two leading candidates have gone
further with artificial intelligence or
a.i by creating life lifelike avatars of
themselves
liberal candidate lee's image promotes
messages tailored for particular areas
of the country
conservative yoon is able to answer
questions who's our enemy he's asked
i'll tell you straight it's north korea
he quips
his creators seem to admit their yoon is
a sassier version of the real person
some of his answers are not always very
politically correct but if we try to be
over cautious we get less feedback from
the public
such ai manipulation has led to claims
of foul play from his rivals but in this
contest with the two leading contenders
running neck and neck just one catchy
online appearance or snappy slogan might
prove the difference between success and
failure rob mcbride al jazeera seoul